ich habe mir die mühe gemacht mal ein
bisschen nach historisch aufzulisten
warum der deutsche sich seit 500 jahren
so ziemlich alles gefallen lassen
und wer sich mal etwas nicht gefallen
lässt dann nach oben durch notiert nach
wie vor 1914 mit 23 19 33 und 39 aber
ich glaube es gibt kaum ein land ich
habe meine nation darf man ja heute
schon fast nicht mehr sagen dass ich so
viel gefallen lässt bis zum heutigen tag
ja schauen sich die bevölkerung an
schaafs geduldig erträgt sie die
steigerung der energiepreise schaafs
geduldig erträgt sie die 7,9 prozent
wahrscheinlich sind die schon schön
gerechnet inflationsrate schaafs
geduldig erträgt der deutsche michel wie
er
meine tägliche
gehirnwäsche gib mir heute bei den
öffentlich-rechtlichen ich glaube das
darf man der runde ja sagen